today we're going to be speaking with
jonathan cohn who's a senior national
correspondent at huffpost and also
author of the book the 10-year war
obamacare and the unfinished crusade for
universal coverage
great to have you on jonathan thanks for
having me on the show
so to start with you know for for a
while the way that particularly
the right but even sometimes democrats
would talk about obamacare was this sort
of like appendage
onto what was there before which could
be
cut off and separated kind of at any
time the language of
well we can we can repeal it and we'll
put something
else in place correct me if i'm wrong
but
we seem to be getting beyond that to
where obamacare is no longer
this kind of standalone appendage to the
healthcare system and it's just
more part of the status quo and it's
it's
becoming more of uh the system that we
would have to modify or work
off of if we want to do further changes
is is my perception accurate as far as
that goes
yeah i mean i think just by default
almost
when when you have something that exists
for as long as the affordable care act
has
existed um uh
you know when you when it's it's it's so
entrenched in our system
now that to pull it out would be very
hard
um and you know uh it's true you know
people have insurance that they rely
upon
uh the healthcare industry
uh is now sort of reoriented itself
around having this program in place
and so pulling it out now is you have to
pull out a whole bunch of wiring
that goes with it and you know it's
interesting because historically this is
one of the
obstacles to passing reform right it's
that the status quo is always hard to
change
well now the affordable care act you
know that's why it was hard to pass the
affordable care act that's
why it was such a fight and continued to
be such a fight
but now it's been around for 10 years
you know it's it's it's now it's part of
the status quo and it's hard to change
and i think you see that in part
by the behavior of the republicans who
don't really talk about repeal anymore
which as you know it wasn't that long
ago it was
it was all they could talk about yeah
and one sometimes
i hear the criticism from folks who
believe
that the affordable care act doesn't go
nearly far enough and i'm under that
umbrella to some degree but but not you
know there's certainly a spectrum within
that
sometimes you hear the critique that
barack obama should have started
at the position of medicare for all and
then negotiated to
something that would have been better
than what we got i don't subscribe to
that exactly because i mean he wasn't
for medicare for all it would be
unlikely to expect someone to start a
negotiation
with a position that's not even their
stated position but
i do think that maybe there would have
been a way to end up with a public
option
having chronicled the way that this all
came together
is it unreasonable for me to think that
some other
approach might have given us a public
option back in 2010.
so i wouldn't say unreasonable certainly
i mean
you know you can any critique is
reasonable and i think you know
reasonable people can debate about this
i'm i will say i'm very skeptical of
that argument though
um for two reasons so number one um
in in studying the history of healthcare
you know it it
there was a century of working on this
basically and almost
without exception it was a failure um
reforming health care is really hard
uh reforming it and you know given the
constraints of the united states
government where the senate and the
power of special interests is even
harder
um the country politically was in a
different place ten years ago than it is
today i mean
i i think a lot of people who are more
progressive minded don't remember that
you know
the country the political conversation
was just a more conservative
conversation we were still in the
back end of the reagan era where
everyone was very skeptical of
government
and the only reason health care reform
got as far as it did and i talked about
this a lot in the book
is that there was a real effort for the
10 years leading
up to the affordable care act so the 10
years before the 10-year war
by democrats to really get together and
say look the only way we're going to get
through this the only way we're going to
overcome our past failures is to all get
on the same page
and and and and medicare for all was
just
not in the conversation it's not like it
was today where had been the subject of
a presidential campaign
for two consecutive uh elections where
you had some invisible proponents who
had a big grassroots movement behind it
so you know if obama had gone in sort of
you know offering to do medicare for all
at the beginning i think just there
would have been
the whole thing would have fallen apart
um you know and in terms
of getting a public option through now
obviously he did endorse a public option
he ran on a public option it was part of
his plan
um at the end of the day they took it
out and a lot of progressives felt like
he never really
fought for it uh and you know there is
something you know there's maybe
something to that i think a lot of
progress has felt like he could have
pushed harder
the flip side of the argument is the
votes were not there um in the united
states senate there were a whole group
of senators
and also in the house there were some
there were some conservative democrats
although it was less of an issue there
but in the senate you had a bunch of
conservative democrats who would not
vote for it
and they had no margin for they needed
every single vote
and uh there i don't it's really hard to
imagine
a scenario where you could get it
through especially given how opposed
the sort of the the sort of most
conservative members of the caucus when
they got to the bill and they were
getting to the end they got to 55
56 votes you know they couldn't get joe
lieberman they couldn't get
ben nelson both lieberman and nelson
were dead set against
the public option and there were others
who were not so vocal about it but were
also against it so i have a hard time
seeing how a bill passes
with a public option in it yeah i mean
that to a lesser extent we saw this with
the 15
minimum wage in the cove in the recent
covet 19 relief bill where
there there were some who were saying
this is as simple as overriding the
parliamentarian and
putting the 15 minimum wage into the
bill
but then it simply wouldn't have passed
because it doesn't it doesn't seem
democrats had the vote i mean obviously
obamacare
was was bigger and changed in a more
systemic way a lot of aspects of how the
system worked
but sometimes maybe people forget that
there's still a lot of a lot of very
centrist democrats
in the in the senate there are it's the
same exact problem today i mean you know
and it's always those you know senators
on the fringe who have the leverage
ultimately
and and they have the leverage let's you
know let's remember why they have the
leverage
i mean obviously if you if you're in a
situation where whether it's you're
going for 60 votes or 50 votes and and
you have exactly the number you need so
that's this you know let's
let's say today you have exactly 50
democrats um
you know obviously any one senator can
object and sort of hold up proceedings
and so they in theory have leverage
but at the end of the day on the
affordable care act at least what
happened was
the people who were in favor of reform
the liberals the progressives
they wanted this very badly i mean this
this this was something you know
getting universal coverage or getting
close to universal coverage it was
you know it was in their dna it's why
they got elected to congress in the
first place
and the more conservative democrats a
lot of them i mean they were in favor of
it
but you know they weren't that
passionate about it and they they would
have been okay
dropping it or at least compromising to
something much much smaller and so you
know in a game of chicken
you know who wins is the one who's
willing to kind of let it you know let
it all go and
fall off the cliff or have the crash or
whatever the the analogy is
and you know the liberal democrats in
the day weren't willing to let this
thing die
and as a result they had less leverage
there's no question that there are some
who
maybe understate or maybe under
understand
the the good things that came from the
affordable care act and
there's a list that probably will bring
a bell to many in my audience including
establishing exchanges
the pre-existing conditions provision um
people
young adults being able to stay on their
parents insurance until age 26 and many
other things
on the other hand when you see that
premiums
even within the exchanges and me as a
self-employed person you know i have one
of those plans
the the price of these premiums is going
up in a cartoonish way that dramatically
outpaces
inflation and cost of living and all
these other things
um it's it's hard to feel as though it
came
close to doing nearly enough what i'm
curious about
is does it help set up whatever the next
step is going to be like what
how does it serve as a bridge to what so
many of us
know has to have more done on it or are
we really just starting
fresh again whenever someone decides to
take it up maybe it'll be this
administration
um it's a bridge and i think it's a very
big bridge um i mean i think
you you know it has put the building
blocks
in place a lot of the key building
blocks of what you know i would consider
a working universal
health care system right really so i
mean uh yeah
absolutely i mean i mean what i consider
you know how do you define universal
health care let's take a step back i
mean
a universal health care system to me and
i think is a sort of generally accepted
definition among people who study this
you know
everybody has insurance um everybody has
good insurance so they're not
uh uh facing bankruptcy
if they have big medical bills they
don't have to worry they don't
care because it costs and there's some
kind of you know
uh uh principle that everybody can get
insurance regardless of pre-existing
medical condition
and then there's you know some kind of
uh control of
cost so you keep the system from
becoming too expensive now
we're not we haven't fully realized any
of those yet but what did the affordable
care act do well first thing is it for
you know it got 20 million people
insurance so right away you've closed
the gap
significantly to the number of people
who don't have insurance you've put
standards in place for what insurance
should
cover the standards aren't strong enough
but they're stronger than what was
before
right similarly there's you know if
you're buying on the exchanges there is
financial assistance there are subsidies
the problem is for a lot of people they
haven't been big enough and so people
like you are paying these crazy premiums
so how do you build on that well
actually we're actually seeing that
right now the biden administration the
democrats
with the covid bill actually took the
first step towards that and which is
they
threw a bunch more money into that
financial assistance so those premiums
will come down the out-of-pocket costs
will come down
they should probably come down further
to really get to a universal coverage
system
and by the way now you need to start
thinking about people with employer
coverage who have high premiums and high
deductibles and what are you going to do
for them
right but you know you've made progress
you've established this key
principle that everybody is entitled to
insurance regardless of pre-existing
condition
and those are two very big building
blocks of a universal coverage system so
there's more to do
yeah but you can certainly build on that
now whether
you build on that by just making the
affordable care act more generous and
opening up the exchanges to more people
or you say look what we really need is
some kind of public option that can
eventually grow
into a for all system or we just need to
go to a medicare for all system i mean
you can take those different paths to
universal coverage but to me at least
i feel like we've moved down that road
regardless yeah the the late
juve reinhardt who's written about this
has your definition of
of what we mean by universal it doesn't
have to be medicare for all
and he talked extensively in in his his
last book i believe it was
um about the way that that those systems
could look
i guess the maybe the zoom out is
conceding all of the things you said if
we make
an obamacare's worth of progress every
11 years
we're a long time from a system that
many of us would consider to be
a system that's working really well yeah
well
i would say you know i mean that's an
interesting way to put it i haven't
quite thought of it in that way but
you know if you think of let's say let's
let's let's create a unit obamacare unit
yeah that's a unit of progress
one obamacare two obamacare so we just
took an obamacare unit
and you know i'd say the 1960s we took
an obamacare size unit with medicare and
medicaid some people would argue that
was bigger
someone also was smaller but let's for
sake of argument say that was an
obamacare kind of leap so
i'm guessing maybe one or two more of
those leaps gets you there pretty much i
mean
you know we did close i mean with the
this obamacare leap cut the number of
uninsured in half
basically so i mean that's you know
that's a pretty big
jump um i mean i think the problem with
that jonathan would be
you know listen like as i'm going to
tell my audience in in our next segment
about a recent um
you know interaction with the medical
system i pay 5 20
20 a month for a silver plan i don't get
a subsidy i don't deserve a subsidy i
can afford it that that's totally fine
um but there's a lot of people who also
are much closer to the edge on when they
get a subsidy which would who would pay
my same 520 a month
and still have a 75 copay and still have
a 2 000
lab deductible to meet it's completely
unaffordable so i feel like for them
to say simply 20 million more people
got care many of them are paying for the
premium but they can't actually afford
to use any of the care and that i think
is not in those numbers
that that is so uh you know just hey we
cut it in half
yeah but a lot of those people aren't
really using the care because they can't
afford to
sure sure so i i the last thing i want
to do is to downplay that in any way and
i spend a lot of time in the book
talking about
you and those people so i completely
agree
and and is why we have so much more to
do um
i would say that it is also true
that for all the people who now have
insurance that they can't use there are
a lot of people who got better insurance
and got cheaper insurance and that also
doesn't show up in the 20 million
right but there are a lot of people who
were buying on their own who actually
now are paying less
and again i do think these enhancements
that came with the coveted relief bill
are going to make a difference because i
mean that i i don't know where you fall
on this spectrum
but one of the things you know it
basically said to everyone who's now
buying on the exchanges if you're
already buying subsidized coverage
you're going to get a bigger subsidy and
if you're one of those people who
doesn't get a subsidy you might be
eligible for one now now again
i think even when that's all done this
insurance is going to be pricey for some
people
and they're going to still be people who
pay too much and again
i don't in any way want to downplay that
or say that's not a reason that we
need to act soon but i do think you know
it is sort of
you know they're it's a tough kind of
get across especially if you're a
politician but somehow you need to get
across the idea that
we actually did accomplish a lot and we
still have
a lot to do yeah i think that that's the
best way to say it much was done
and much remains to be done um
and uh of course you know in these next
couple of years when democrats control
the white house and the senate and the
house of representatives we'll see
whether
anything does get done and certainly
what was in the coveted relief bill
also shouldn't shouldn't be understated
the book shows both sides and the book
is called the 10-year war
obamacare and the unfinished crusade for
universal coverage
we've been speaking with the book's
author jonathan cohn
jonathan i really appreciate your time
today thanks uh
for uh having me on the show